my plan for healthcare cost a lot of
money it cost 740 billion dollars it
doesn't cost $30 on Medicare for all
costs are going to go up for wealthier
individuals and costs are going to go up
for giant corporations but for
hardworking families across this country
costs are going to go down every study
done shows that medicare for all is the
most cost effective approach it says
that we will no longer have private
insurance as we know it and that means
that 149 million Americans will no
longer be able to have their current
insurance I don't think that's a bold
idea I think it's a bad idea I proposed
Medicare for all who wanted and if we're
right as progressives that that public
alternative is better then the American
people will figure that out for
themselves this discussion is given the
American public a headache what they
want to know is that they're gonna have
health care and cost will not be a
barrier to getting it in my proposal we
Medicare for America it says everyone
who's uninsured will be enrolled in
Medicare everyone who's in sufficiently
insured cannot afford it can move over
to Medicare the difference between what
I support and what you support Vice
President Biden is that you require them
to opt in and I would not require them
to opt in they would automatically be
enrolled
so I know a lot of doctors we have to
change the incentive so instead of
revenue and activity people are focused
on our health look I I'm clearing what I
believe I believe in Medicare for all as
a person who has an ideal I know we
cannot sacrifice progress on the altar
of purity